yesterday's briefing was more like a
spanking first after the press had spent
weeks concocting a fantasy rift between
Trump and foul Chi the doc showed up to
end that dream the first and only time
that dr. Burks and I went in and
formally made a recommendation to the
president to actually have a quote shut
down in the sense of not really shut
down but to really have strong
mitigation we discussed it obviously
they would be concerned by some that in
fact that might have some negative
consequences nonetheless the president
listened to the recommendation and went
to the mitigation so Trump took the
experts advice the moment it was offered
and how did the media respond did they
think oh wow
we were wrong to waste America's time
with stupid high school cafeteria gossip
no they acted like a baby losing its
favorite toy everything I do is
voluntarily please don't even imply that
hmm it's finally happened even the
calmest guy in the room hates the media
as much as everyone else does
note to media when fowey thinks you suck
that's a real diagnosis take two months
off and don't call us in the morning and
after weeks of the media pretending they
were on top of the virus while claiming
Trump had blood on his hands what did
Trump do when any old TV Pro would do
he dropped a montage to show how wrong
the media was how worried should
Americans be about coronavirus toward a
virus is not gonna cause a major in the
United States his team is on it they've
been responsive late at night early in
the morning and
thus far been doing everything that they
can do and I want to say thank you
now the montage was a media trick that
only the media is allowed to pool so you
know what pissed him off
how dare he use their own words against
them somehow that's propaganda in the
briefing room on Twitter their
incontinent outrage spilled onto their
screens check out these sweaty CNN
headlines you can almost see the steam
coming out of jets suckers ears and why
because only the media has the power to
destroy your reputation but don't you
dare turn the tables on them which Trump
did yesterday Trump also mentioned that
we have a lot of extra ventilators maybe
we should drop them off for today's
briefing all right we have a because
montages are the media's
bread-and-butter we have a montage of
the media responding to Trump's montage
montage visa montage let's roll
he started this briefing with that anti
media propaganda video which is nothing
sort of disgraceful some kind of
backward looking edited video propaganda
that was propaganda aired at taxpayer
expense in the White House briefing room
this is a temperament issue where he's
consumed with ego in insecurity the
president at times combative angry that
is the biggest meltdown I have ever seen
from a President of the United States in
my career that is a mate Dana to see
people the media talk about ego makes me
laugh hysterically at them
David Gregory talking about ego and
acting as though how dare they use their
own words those are their own words
that's not propaganda when it's their
own words
sorry it's one of my very favorite
things to do when I was a press
secretary was basically just quote
somebody's words back at them and and
sometimes it was the media but often it
was or whatever the opposition was
saying at the time and it is really
effective I do love it that dr. pouchy
finally said enough you know he has been
so accessible to all sorts of media
including all the major networks but I
think some of his most effective work
has been that he's
Shoni he's been willing to do barstool
poor sports and part of my take he's out
there everywhere to try to spread a
message but the problem is one never
answer a hypothetical that you that's
kind of like PR 101 make sure you always
tell your clients never answer a
hypothetical because that's what doctor
about you did you hypotheticals are
meant to sow division and that's one of
the reasons you never answer them
because there's never actually a good
answer because you can't provide all the
context and then we'll cherry-pick
things to try to hurt you so I'm glad
that doctor felt you push back on on
that and I think we're all better off
for it because the more he's able and
willing to go out there and talk to all
of us the better off we'll be Dana what
if you answered a hypothetical that is a
hypothetical and I won't answer it no
see how that's done yes try again that's
why you're the press secretary and I'm
just some schmuck in a sweater
all right wha take it apart say how
disgusting and unprofessional this was
well I'm glad you said it
III think you know when you look at that
when you look at that video
he doesn't just take people's words he
actually omits words so that they say
things that are favorable to him and
that's why people would say this is a
distortion and he learned that some CNN
but to me it I don't he's the president
he's the president he's our president
Greg he said he has information at a
time I mean he's totally hit me in the
way that he puts out you out there look
like foul she was in a hostage video
yeah we got my today today the president
hang on guys today the president comes
out with a tweet in which he's attacking
the governor's only come I says the he's
like the captain bligh on the mutiny on
the bounty
he must someone that's got to tell the
president that the captain bligh is a
villain the crew the crew is abused and
that's why they they rebel against him
and yet the president says oh he you
know he's seen mutiny on the bounty and
tell the governors they owe the captain
in the
captain has control this is how I mean
is he it's like an alternate reality
what is like god I do want you because
he should be predictable he should be
saying that he's protecting the American
people not about to abuse the rebellion
of the governors so Jesse oh yeah Greg
while he's running the country doing a
pretty good job go Tate let's get Jesse
it and then the judge both great can I
make one quick point on the Republican
no no no you hear Republicans right now
who are up in arms over the fact that he
says he has total authority that's the
net one because all right Jesse the
right judge one take a lap I would say
this I would say the president really
appreciates the power of the media and
he takes bad coverage very personally
and he's taken it upon himself to police
the media and the media is squealing
like a bunch of stuck pigs because
they've never been policed before
remember for years and years and years
it was only the media that had access to
raw footage could edit tape and could
distribute it now every American
including the president has access to
the same footage so it's not propaganda
when you show the media what they said
he just held a mirror up to the media
and basically said how dare you get it
wrong and then come into a briefing room
and wag your finger at me like that and
the point is this there's just a
wrestling match at this point between
Trump and the press over this narrative
and the narrative they want to sell as
Trump was late and wrong and the
president's saying no I wasn't and pulls
out Falchi Falchi says listen every
single time I made a scientific
recommendation to the president he took
immediate action that destroys the press
narrative that said he was late and
wrong and anybody that ever now from
this day forward comes up on the show
and tells me the pleasant president was
laid it wrong I'm pushing foul Chi in
their face and they want to do it with
pleasure all right judge last word yeah
yeah well you could push frowsy but you
can't push other people
you know what one one let me talk let me
tell you this there is nothing that is
more important than the truth the truth
is that the what was put up by the
president is what they said period end
of that story number two not close
enough ouchie the react okay let me
finish Juan the reaction of pouchy when
they tried to say to him you're being
forced to say this was so shocking that
everyone looked at and said this guy is
serious I mean he's not making this
stuff up the president has been living
for three years with with networks with
CNN and MSNBC who do nothing but call
him names 24/7 he has a right at some
point to defend himself and point to the
fact that their propaganda is a lie and
the best way to do that is with their
own words period end of that story you
know it's interesting he's basically
shattered the media ceiling like it used
to be the media could only manipulate
the environment he's saying you know
what I'm gonna take your words and do
exactly back to you it's new ground you
could argue a it's it's changing things
for the better for the worst who knows
but I loved it